but three four three
their issue was they always seem to get
something wrong
they never put it all together
yes and then when they did because I
think Halo infinite is only a couple of
couple of things away from being truly
great like I I quite enjoyed the
campaign of infinite I thought it was
great I 100 of it all the collectibles
I actually thought it was legitimately
good at the same time I completely
understand the issues people had like
had Halo infinite
been stronger visually yes
they had a bit stronger visually
and had it had its world had a little
more variety of different biomes nothing
you would have seen far less complaints
about Halos I agree campaign